Money is a top cause of stress for many Americans. That's according to the latest stress in America survey conducted by the American Psychological Association. Stress can negatively affect health and even contribute to chronic health problems such as diabetes and heart disease. In this episode, we talk with psychologist and researcher Linda Gallo about managing stress and how it affects people from different economic and ethnic backgrounds. I'm Audrey Hamilton and this is speaking of psychology. Linda Gallo is a professor of psychology at San Diego State University. She is also co-director of the Institute for Behavioral and Community Health Studies, which promotes research aimed at making behavioral science applicable to medicine and health care. Dr. Gallo has extensively studied how stress and other psychological problems can lead to increased risk of chronic disease,
金钱是许多美国人压力的主要来源。这是根据美国心理学会进行的最新“美国压力”调查得出的结论。压力会对健康产生负面影响，甚至导致糖尿病和心脏病等慢性健康问题。在本期节目中，我们采访了心理学家兼研究员琳达·加洛（Linda Gallo），探讨如何管理压力，以及压力如何影响来自不同经济和种族背景的人们。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿（Audrey Hamilton），这是《心理学谈话》。琳达·加洛是圣地亚哥州立大学的心理学教授。她还是行为与社区健康研究所的联合主任，该研究所致力于推动将行为科学应用于医学和医疗保健的研究。加洛博士广泛研究了压力和其他心理问题如何导致慢性病风险增加，
and she has helped develop a number of psychological interventions aimed at lowering disease risk in lower income populations. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Gallo. Thank you very much for having me. I think there are many people who are aware that stress can negatively affect our health. But what are some side effects of stress that people may not expect? You know, what sort of diseases can be aggravated or even caused by stress? Well, she was actually equipped to deal with stress, and stress can be beneficial, at least initially,
她还帮助开发了许多旨在降低低收入人群疾病风险的心理干预措施。感谢您加入我们，加洛博士。非常感谢您的邀请。我想很多人都知道压力会对我们的健康产生负面影响。但压力有哪些人们可能意想不到的副作用呢？您知道，什么样的疾病可能会因压力而加重甚至引起？嗯，其实人天生具备应对压力的能力，压力在最初阶段甚至可能是有益的，
because it allows us to avoid danger and face challenges. But stress becomes unhealthy when it is unrelenting, and people do not experience opportunities to recover. So in these cases, stress can lead to physical problems, things like headaches and stomach aches, and also mental health issues, such as anxiety, trouble sleeping. And then over time, the toll of stress in the body accumulates and can contribute to chronic physical conditions, such as heart disease, diabetes, and other illnesses. And in addition, some conditions can be made worse by stress. For example, stress can exacerbate autoimmune conditions like rheumatoid arthritis. and yeah, something else that people may not be aware of is that chronic stress can also affect our immune system in a way that makes us more vulnerable to acute viral illnesses like cold and the flu.
因为它能让我们避开危险并迎接挑战。但当压力持续不断，且人们没有机会恢复时，压力就会变得不健康。在这种情况下，压力会导致身体问题，比如头痛和胃痛，以及心理健康问题，如焦虑、睡眠困难。随着时间的推移，压力对身体造成的损害会累积，并可能导致慢性身体疾病，如心脏病、糖尿病和其他疾病。此外，一些疾病可能会因压力而恶化。例如，压力会加剧类风湿性关节炎等自身免疫性疾病。还有一点人们可能没有意识到，慢性压力也会以某种方式影响我们的免疫系统，使我们更容易受到感冒和流感等急性病毒性疾病的侵袭。
But it's true that we're more likely to get sick with those conditions when we're under stress as well. What's the difference between good stress and bad stress? I think that bad stress is the kind that makes us distressed or upset. And when those feelings continue over time, that can be particularly detrimental to the body. sometimes stress prepares us to face a challenge. And if we have the resources to meet that challenge, then it can be a positive thing that that sort of incites us to prepare and get ready for things like an important event or a meeting or things like that.
但确实，当我们处于压力之下时，我们更容易患上这些疾病。好压力和坏压力之间有什么区别？我认为坏压力是那种让我们感到痛苦或不安的压力。当这些感觉持续存在时，对身体的伤害尤其大。有时压力会让我们准备好迎接挑战。如果我们有资源去应对挑战，那么这可能是一件积极的事情，它会激励我们为重要事件、会议等事情做好准备。
So in those cases, it's okay, but it's really the situations that are uncontrollable or that cause us a lot of distress that end up being most unhealthy for us. Now, APA's 2015 Stress in America survey tells us that money continues to be a top source of stress for Americans from all economic backgrounds. Now, however, in this last survey, you know, lower income households reported higher overall stress levels than those living in higher income households. Can you explain why we're seeing such a stress gap between lower and higher income families? So there are a number of factors that contribute to higher levels of stress in people with lower
所以在这些情况下，它是没问题的，但真正对我们最不健康的是那些无法控制或导致我们极度痛苦的情况。现在，美国心理学会2015年的“美国压力”调查告诉我们，金钱仍然是所有经济背景的美国人压力的主要来源。然而，在最近的这次调查中，低收入家庭报告的总体压力水平高于高收入家庭。您能解释一下为什么我们看到低收入家庭和高收入家庭之间存在如此大的压力差距吗？导致低收入人群压力水平较高的因素有很多，
incomes. First, as we know from the stress in America survey, financial stress is a very common cause of stress overall, and it's more likely to occur if, people have lower incomes. But people with lower incomes may also experience exposure to stress across many other domains in their lives. They may work in jobs that are stressful because they are demanding but don't allow a lot of control or their work environments may be unhealthy, for example. They could have a lot of noise or exposure to toxins in their work environment.
首先，正如我们从“美国压力”调查中所知，经济压力是导致压力的一个非常普遍的原因，如果人们收入较低，这种情况就更容易发生。但低收入人群在生活的许多其他领域也可能面临压力。例如，他们从事的工作可能因为要求高但缺乏自主权而充满压力，或者他们的工作环境可能不健康。例如，他们的工作环境中可能有很大的噪音或接触到毒素。
And they may also be exposed to more stressful community environments, community environments that have less green space, more traffic, crowding, or even violence. And then the other component is that in addition to increased exposure to stress, people with lower incomes often have fewer resources to cope with stresses that they face. So this includes both tangible resources like health insurance, the savings account, a reliable source of transportation, and also psychosocial resources, such as a source of social support and a sense of control over one's life and destiny. So this can cause stress to escalate and continue and create an unhealthy cycle.
他们也可能暴露在压力更大的社区环境中，这些社区绿地较少、交通拥堵、人口稠密，甚至存在暴力。另一个因素是，除了压力暴露增加外，低收入人群往往缺乏应对压力的资源。这包括有形资源，如医疗保险、储蓄账户、可靠的交通工具，以及心理社会资源，如社会支持来源和对自己生活及命运的掌控感。因此，这会导致压力升级并持续存在，形成一个不健康的循环。
And you mentioned this. How important is family and social support when it comes to managing stress? So I think we all recognize that family can be both a, critical source to support and well-being and also a source of stress for many people. And people with cohesive and supportive families tend to live healthier lifestyles and have better health than those who have less supportive families. But when there are problems in the family relationships or when a family member is having difficulties, this can be an important source of stress.
您提到了这一点。在管理压力方面，家庭和社会支持有多重要？我认为我们都认识到，家庭既是支持和幸福的关键来源，对许多人来说也是压力的来源。家庭凝聚力强且相互支持的人往往生活方式更健康，健康状况也比那些家庭支持较少的人更好。但当家庭关系出现问题或家庭成员遇到困难时，这可能成为压力的重要来源。
And in addition, as we were just saying, we know that having good social support, having someone to talk about problems with, people who can provide help or guidance is very important to help. And that support can come from family members or friends and also from other sources like formal support groups or religious organizations. Overall, social support is an important resource for coping with stress, and it's also more generally important for maintaining good health and well-being. It's just something that comes up pretty frequently in your research, looking at those factors that contribute to how people manage stress. Absolutely, yes. And the point that I raised initially about family being both important sorts of support and stress,
此外，正如我们刚才所说，我们知道拥有良好的社会支持，有可以倾诉问题的人，有能够提供帮助或指导的人，对健康非常重要。这种支持可以来自家人或朋友，也可以来自其他来源，如正式的支持小组或宗教组织。总的来说，社会支持是应对压力的重要资源，对于维持良好的健康和幸福感也更为重要。这在您的研究中经常出现，即观察那些影响人们如何管理压力的因素。绝对是这样。我最初提到的关于家庭既是重要的支持来源也是压力来源的观点，
Sometimes people mention all of the time that they ask them, you know, what are the most relevant stressors or resources in your life? Family comes up sort of in both of those questions. Right. I can imagine. Both sides of the coin with that one. Exactly. Your research focuses on people from different ethnic backgrounds as well. Can you talk a little about what, if any, differences you found in how various ethnic groups experience and manage psychosocial health problems?
有时人们在被问到“你生活中最相关的压力源或资源是什么？”时，总是会提到家庭。家庭在两个问题中都会出现。没错。我可以想象。这就像硬币的两面。正是如此。您的研究也关注来自不同种族背景的人。您能谈谈在不同种族群体如何经历和管理心理社会健康问题方面，您发现了什么差异吗？
Well, a person's cultural background can influence. the experience and expression of emotions and sick of social health problems, and also how they go about seeking help, the types of coping styles they have, and how much stigma they may attach to having a mental health problem. In some cultural context, it may be more socially acceptable to report physical health problems than mental health problems. So sometimes people from ethnic minority groups might report things like physical symptoms, such as stomach aches, headaches, or pain when they're experiencing a lot of stress or depression.
嗯，一个人的文化背景会影响其对情绪和心理社会健康问题的体验和表达，以及他们寻求帮助的方式、应对风格，以及他们对患有心理健康问题可能产生的耻辱感。在某些文化背景下，报告身体健康问题可能比报告心理健康问题在社会上更容易被接受。因此，有时来自少数族裔群体的人在经历大量压力或抑郁时，可能会报告身体症状，如胃痛、头痛或疼痛。
All of us have those symptoms arise when stress is high, but sometimes those might be the ones that are primarily reported in certain cultural groups. And unfortunately, we know that psychosocial health problems are undertreated in general, but this is especially the case in diverse groups. Racial and ethnic disparities in mental health treatment are very well documented in the United States, and ethnic minorities are also more likely to seek out for behavioral health problems in primary care settings and less likely to seek them in an outpatient mental health care. settings. So it may be that the trend toward integrated care models where behavioral and physical health care are integrated within the same context as a potential avenue to reduce disparities and improve care for diverse groups. And you think this is mainly related to stigma issues or just lack of a feeling of effectiveness? Yeah, I think there's a number of issues going on. So one is the stigma attached to having mental health problems. One is kind of preferences about what's most
我们所有人压力大时都会出现这些症状，但有时这些症状在某些文化群体中是主要的报告内容。不幸的是，我们知道心理社会健康问题在总体上治疗不足，但在多元化群体中情况尤为严重。在美国，心理健康治疗中的种族和民族差异记录非常详尽，少数族裔也更有可能在初级保健环境中寻求行为健康问题的帮助，而不太可能在门诊心理健康护理环境中寻求帮助。因此，将行为和身体健康护理整合在同一环境中的综合护理模式，可能是减少差异并改善多元化群体护理的一个潜在途径。您认为这主要是与耻辱感问题有关，还是仅仅因为缺乏有效感？是的，我认为存在许多问题。一个是患有心理健康问题所带来的耻辱感。一个是关于什么最
most comfortable to talk about in the words that people like to use to explain how they're feeling. And in terms of health care seeking, part of its stigma, there's a lot of access issues. Having access to good care and culturally appropriate access to care can be a challenge for many people. So there's a lot of different barriers that could interfere with health thinking, in particular, for ethnically diverse groups. So what would you recommend people do if they think their stress levels are out of control? And, you know, you can talk about this from different groups. I mean, and we're talking about lower income or different ethnic backgrounds or just people who may be more apt to go out and get care.
最舒服的谈话方式，以及人们喜欢用什么词来解释他们的感受。在寻求医疗保健方面，部分原因是耻辱感，还有很多获取途径的问题。获得良好的护理和文化上适当的护理对许多人来说可能是一个挑战。因此，有很多不同的障碍可能会干扰健康寻求行为，特别是对于种族多元化的群体。那么，如果人们认为自己的压力水平失控了，您会建议他们做什么？而且，您可以从不同群体的角度来谈谈。我的意思是，我们谈论的是低收入群体、不同种族背景的人，或者仅仅是那些可能更倾向于去寻求护理的人。
But, you know, what are some of the recommendations from psychologists as to what they can do to get their stress under control? Well, if someone does feel overwhelmed by stress, they can definitely seek help from a psychologist or another mental health provider. In addition, they can stay in touch with people who can provide social support. So they can ask for help from family and friends or community or religious organizations, whatever setting is the most comfortable. for them to seek support. And that's something obviously that anyone can do. And as I was mentioning earlier, social support can be important in maintaining health at all times, not just when we're under stress.
但是，心理学家对于他们如何控制压力有什么建议吗？嗯，如果有人确实感到压力过大，他们绝对可以向心理学家或其他心理健康提供者寻求帮助。此外，他们可以与能够提供社会支持的人保持联系。他们可以向家人、朋友、社区或宗教组织寻求帮助，无论哪种环境对他们来说最舒适。这显然是任何人都可以做到的。正如我之前提到的，社会支持在任何时候对维持健康都很重要，不仅仅是在我们承受压力时。
And we also know that regular exercise is an excellent means of reducing your coping with stress. There's a lot of research showing that engaging in moderate activity for about 30 minutes a day can improve mood. And of course, we know that has many physical benefits as well. And walking can be ideal for a lot of people because it doesn't require any special equipment or gym memberships. And it can be done with a friend or family member as well, which can also create social support or someone can join a walking group in their neighborhood,
我们也知道，定期锻炼是减少和应对压力的绝佳手段。大量研究表明，每天进行约30分钟的中等强度活动可以改善情绪。当然，我们也知道这也有许多身体上的好处。对于许多人来说，步行是理想的选择，因为它不需要任何特殊设备或健身房会员资格。而且它可以和朋友或家人一起进行，这也可以创造社会支持，或者人们可以加入社区的步行小组，
things like that. And since stress can really get in the way of activities like these, it's important to set aside time regularly for healthy and relaxing behaviors, because I think as we all know, we know it's good for us, we know it's healthy, but when stress arises, often we let go of the behaviors that could help us deal with it most effectively. Well, Dr. Gallo, thank you so much for joining us. you taking the time. Thank you very much. It was a pleasure to talk with you, Audrey. Find more tips on how to manage stress and read the complete Stress in America report on our website at speakingofpsychology.org. With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology,
诸如此类。由于压力确实会阻碍这些活动，因此定期留出时间进行健康和放松的行为非常重要，因为我认为正如我们所知，我们知道这对我们有好处，我们知道它是健康的，但当压力出现时，我们往往会放弃那些最能有效帮助我们应对压力的行为。好的，加洛博士，非常感谢您加入我们。感谢您抽出时间。非常感谢。很高兴与您交谈，奥黛丽。在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上查找更多关于如何管理压力的建议，并阅读完整的“美国压力”报告。我是美国心理学会《心理学谈话》节目的
I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。